hey guys i'm philip molina and this is
the breakdown of the campaign story in
star wars battlefront - and i'm gonna be
covering just yeah that story of our
newest Star Wars hero I Denver CO
pointing out all the Easter eggs I
noticed the references to the Star Wars
movies and a non Star Wars reference I
spotted and since this story is an
authentic addition to the Star Wars
universe I'm also gonna point out all
the new tidbits of history and lore that
have now been officially added to Star
Wars and not just the main period the
game is set in but there's even stuff
leading right up into the last Jedi so
whether you plan to play the game or not
just go ahead and lean back and get
ready to take it all in because this
campaign feels like a new Star Wars
movie just got added to the franchise so
I think you even just enjoy hearing the
story and quick side note I played the
game for like 10 hours straight looking
for all the Easter eggs and references I
could find which means I pissed off a
lot of the characters by taking too long
and I died a whole bunch so take it easy
on me let's get started the game opens
with a traditional opening to every Star
Wars film the texts reminding us that
this is a galaxy far far away and then
very specifically a pan down in space
usually to a ship or a planet this one
happens to be to multiple ships jumping
out of hyperspace one of the ships we
see is the invincible faith and MCAD
rebel security star cruiser and that's
our first clue as to when this story is
starting off since that ship was
operational mostly in the time leading
up to the Battle of Endor so we're right
amidst return to the Jedi days here and
this thing that follows brings us our
first big film reference because this is
all meant to serve as an almost
alternate version of how we first met
gen or so in the very first trailer
actually for rogue one except here we're
meeting the protagonist of this story I
Denver CO like Jin she's also being held
by rebel forces as we get a rundown of a
list that shows she's quite the
experienced threat there are a lot more
homage as like this one to come item by
the way is the leader of Inferno squad
after the events of rogue one with the
plants being successfully stolen by the
rebels the M
I formed this new group I like to think
of them as kind of SEAL team 6 but in
Star Wars and their first major task was
to wipe out the partisans who were rebel
extremists led by of course saw Guerrera
they're also known as dreamers - all
this stuff that's covered in the
battlefront - companion book Inferno
squad these events are taking place
about four years after the formation of
the team I'll fill you in on the rest of
Inferno squad as we meet them but just
the main other stuff about iDEN she's a
huge badass she graduated at the top of
the Imperial Academy she flew a TIE
fighter for the Empire at the freaking
Battle of Yavin in a new hope and she
somehow survived that her father Garrick
versio is the freaking Admiral of the
fleet and I got to meet the actress that
plays her in real life Janina gavankar
and she's just as alpha dominant in real
life and I should know I'm easily
intimidated so back to the story the
rebels have captured iDEN and there's a
mention of possibly recruiting her which
is actually a really delicate subject
frightened because one of her previous
missions we learned this in the book had
her going undercover as a double agent
but that meant that everyone around her
thought she really was a traitor to the
Empire and it kind of ruined her life so
just you know sore subject for her she
proceeds to get a bit more aggressive
when a threat is made to her droid which
is actually our first clue that items a
bit different Imperials aren't known for
caring for their droids or forming
attachments the way rebels do but iDEN
steam has come to really rely on this
one particular IB 10 secret roid and in
the gameplay you're gonna come to be a
big fan of it - when the coast is clear
iDEN uses her nearby helmet to transmit
the code of DC 6-2 6-2 roit that's in
another place on the ship that code
contains a reference to TK 6 - 6 an
annoying character on the Star Wars
rebels TV show but then the game puts us
in the eyes of the I beat Android and
right away I know what you're thinking
oh crap that's Nina
Lando's copilot from the Battle of Endor
and also the one that shows up in an
x-wing in force awakens but if you think
that you're racist because that's just
another soulless ton who happens to look
like Nina shame the biggest clip for me
that it was different was that we've
never heard any nubs speak with a voice
that's so deep and chocolaty smooth
singing to you is never easy also this
nervous protocol droid sounds a lot like
c-3po but this guy is all silver so
that's likely not him either
after the ID 10 droid shocks not any nub
or n and then we get our first look at a
gonk droid who always cracked me up
because gunk of course is basic language
for a walking trashcan moving forward
the ID 10 navigates the air shafts to
help identify and depending on how fast
you move you might get a glimpse of
could it be Princess Leia
I'm gonna say no that's probably not her
actually as you go through the game you
run into so many Princess Leia look like
they can't all be Leia especially
because spoiler alert you end up a
wrecking a bunch of him when you're
fighting for the Empire but what I will
point out is that this is a good
reminder that Leia is a very popular
figure in this galaxy and her hairstyles
become trends that many rebel women
choose to copy as we keep exploring I'll
give you one last no that's not who you
think it is when we see this blue
Twilight who may look like a familiar
Jedi but that's not her mostly because
she was killed during order 66 in the
prequels remember man it's really easy
to be accidentally racist when aliens
come into play some easy to miss moments
here come in various overheard commands
sent by none other than Admiral Ackbar
since this is taking place right before
the Battle of Endor all of these rebel
ships are going to be needed for the
attempt to wipe out the Imperial fleet
and separately the Death Star to play
around enough and you're also gonna hear
some whispers around Lando Calrissian in
this area as we move forward the ID tent
helps out in a scape so there's a nice
close-up here of Eden's armor back plate
there's a famous joke in Star Wars about
stormtroopers having this very
particular back plate but no one knows
what it's for a lot of people call it
the Twinkies and donut design and joke
that it's got some spare food in it when
I D 10 attaches at that same point
I got a wanders that may be what these
back plates are supposed to be used for
in this way all sorts of stormtrooper
attachments to droids or other gear
maybe as I didn't currently talks to her
team we find out the real reason she's
there the rumors figured out you wanted
to be caught
this mission is actually a really big
deal and it's all new to the Star Wars
universe and
affects the greater history and I'm just
gonna explain some stuff here so Sullust
you might remember being mentioned a lot
in Return of the Jedi that's the planet
where the rebel ships are going to
rendezvous right before the Battle of
Endor their plan was to get the Imperial
fleet to see hey something's up at
Sullust and make them all leave Endor to
go figure out what's up then the rebels
could actually take down the Death Star
to much more easily as it would be left
without its protective fleet but now
because of these discussions happening
in Battlefront 2 we're learning that
higher-level imperial agents are already
fully aware of this rebel plan to
distract them and that finally explains
why the Emperor is so dismissive of
Darth Vader's concerns about rebels of
massing at Sullust one of the reports of
the rebel fleet massing near Sullust it
is of no concern he already knows about
the plan what's really interesting here
is that the Inferno squad seemed to know
even more than Darth Vader does so hi
this mission is actually an essential
part of what ends up happening in the
space above Endor
this is all very easy to miss by the way
but we learn here that while the Empire
may have secretly known about the rebels
distraction plan it turns out the rebels
actually intercepted a transmission that
would have told them that their plan had
already leaked to the Empire
[Laughter]
[Music]
if they were to successfully decode this
transmission they would have changed
their plan and also hey they wouldn't
have been so shocked when they see
what's waiting for them when they get to
Endor in other words it would never have
happened if I didn't didn't erase this
information right now
then as iDEN moves on to make her escape
from the ship I'll just quickly point
out that if you've got your are beshte
english dictionary handy you can read
all about items by oh and history on
this screen but it's pretty redundant
too info that I've already given you so
let's just move on I didn't escape sin
probably the most badass way we've ever
seen in Star Wars and she rejoins her
ship which is the home base to Inferno
squad itself it's called the Corvis and
a few moments later we meet her main
teammates first up agent Gideon hask so
lieutenant Gideon hask is the last of
his family and he's got the motivation
of having had his parents killed by a
rebel bomb remember how iDEN was at the
top of her class at the academy well a
few years ahead of her tasks was at the
top of his class
so he's second in command here but
clearly he wants to be in charge and
he's kind of I'd ins friend but also
kind of her rival if he looks familiar
he's actually played by the actor who
portrays Quentin Lance on arrow we also
meet agent del Miko that's first and
last name there del amico he's actually
really interesting he's super versatile
unlike the other two he started out as
just a lonely stormtrooper then he got
promoted to being a short trooper who
was stationed at scurry so he was one of
these guys in rogue one then he got
promoted again to tie pilot and then
again to chief engineer of a Star
Destroyer and then finally landed here
on Inferno squad you know there's
actually another member of Inferno squad
who was killed before the events of the
game you can read about her in the book
but she was real cool because she was an
amazing sniper and had a photographic
memory which are two of like the most
intimidating talents you can have and
after this ominous threat today
the game finally begins moving on we
find ourselves right smack in the middle
of the Battle of Endor and our view
we're actually getting a brand new angle
of what we saw in Return of the Jedi the
crashing of Darth Vader's Super Star
Destroyer the executor into the Death
Star and I love this moment where
Admiral Garrick versio says well gee do
you remember why he was even put in
charge who put him there again no I
can't believe so then Inferno squad
takes a trip onto the surface of Endor
and their mission is directly tied to
what han was up to in Return of the Jedi
because they have to go figure out
what's up with the Death Star's shield
generator not working and see if they
can power it up again of course they
don't realize that our heroes just blew
it up and a little later while Inferno
squad is busy making plans the rebellion
laughs today we wipe out that scum once
and for all
this is another brand-new angle on a
classic event that we've seen before but
what's fascinating is that this
positioning means Inferno Squad is very
close to where our beloved characters
are in Return of the Jedi our rebel
friends are really lucky they didn't
happen across paths with these elite
assassins in this section I may be
confusing to understand why if you're
playing as Imperial soldiers so many 80s
T's are firing at you but this is all a
callback to Chewbacca commandeering and
a TST in Jedi the idea is that a bunch
of other people and he walks got the
same idea
unfortunately this totally leads to
their demise a bit later and one of the
coolest visuals of this game as iDEN you
have to get away from Endor in a TIE
fighter but you have to navigate all
this annoying debris that debris of
course is the remains of the Death Star
- look there's a part of the disarray
this is a bigger deal than it seems
because before this a lot of people have
always thought the Death Star explosion
left it completely atomized as a no
debris just powder and droplets but
these are actually huge chunks they're
actually really hard to navigate as
evidenced by my poor piloting just as I
didn't was making a very important point
the Empire will change just like it did
when they destroyed the first Death Star
we adapt whoops
now in some non-canon star wars stories
a lot of people have teased that the
idea that the Emperor or some part of
him actually survived the destruction of
the Death Star but one of the biggest
arguments against that was well if it's
been totally atomized there's nothing
left of them this all shows that that
wasn't the case just saying there could
be Emperor body chunks floating around
out there when I didn't finally rejoins
her father the Admiral and his star
destroyed the Eviscerator which by the
way he's really lucky that it got out of
that huge battle unscathed this is where
she learns that the Emperor is dead
though the Admiral does leave out the
embarrassing detail that the
all-powerful Emperor was just kind of
casually thrown to his death but what's
really fascinating here is we're seeing
how quickly the Empire reacts to the
death of their leader so what happens
now we retired this is literally moments
after his death and there are already
plans to retaliate no period of mourning
also know what iDEN says that they must
take from the rebels
that's an obvious reference to what Luke
Skywalker brought to the rebellion and
then we finally meet one of my favorite
recent additions to the droid family
these creepy messenger sentinel droids i
actually love these guys though there
let me take a selfie with one they're
delightful now we've actually met these
droids before if you've read shattered
Empire in part 2 Imperial captain
doo-bot gets a very similar message to
this one so actually I don't think it's
as special and private a message as the
Admiral thinks it is this messengers
presence is a great honor as for this
operation speaking at once operation
cinder it covers instructions being sent
all over the place right now and you can
almost think of it as a non Jedi
specific order 66 the Emperor after his
death just wants to bring death and
destruction to a bunch of planets that
have large populations so you can squash
any further people from eventually
joining the rebellion like if your
planet produces freedom lovers you got
to go moving forward we head to the fond
or shipyards where they built that same
huge superstar destroyer that we saw a
nosedive a bit earlier the purpose of
this mission is to obtain some special
satellites and iden doesn't understand
why yet above pretty quickly rebel
forces attack these shipyards and I just
find this really funny that they're
shocked because during this same time
period rebel forces attack this same
shipyard over like 12 times already so
you think they'd be better at guarding
the place by now
but back to these satellites they may
seem unimportant at this time but the
shattered Empire comic story has
actually already let us know these
satellites can be used to not only wipe
out electronics causing a planet-wide
blackout but they can also disrupt
weather like geo storm style we'll get
back to those later moving on iDEN an
inferno squad gets sent on a kind of
side mission to pilio to destroy the
emperor's observatory because there's
concern about too many of his old
artifacts getting into the hands of the
rebellion and it's actually delle miko
who goes down to take care of that
business but this is also where we see
that pilio happens to be housing r2d2
and one mr. luke skywalker and here's
what's awesome you get to play as luke
now and as luke because you're such a
good guy you end up helping save del
even though he's an imperial agent and
around here del drops a really
fascinating detail i've heard a hundred
stories about the jedi they terrified me
as a boy in carson but you this reveals
to us and not only were the jedi reduced
to being a myth leading up to the events
of a new hope but also that myth it was
miss portrayed as a horror story
obviously it's Imperial propaganda it
turns out the Jedi were almost like the
boogeyman of their time which makes me
think about the real boogeyman like
maybe he's not such a bad guy either
also when del says that luck has brought
them together Luke says there's always
more to it good luck this is a clear
reference to Obi Wan's line to Han after
Luke nails this training with the
blaster shield down in my experience
there's no such thing as luck there's
also an interesting moment when they
realize the Emperor's Observatory can
only be opened with the force which is
shocking to del but obviously not to
Luke why would be able to have a vote
that can only be opened using the force
remember how earlier I pointed out home
Ferno squad knew some high-level
top-secret stuff that even Darth Vader
didn't know well this moment informs us
that even top-level people like that
still somehow are not aware of the
Emperor's force abilities that is such a
huge secret that was kept for so long
once inside the Emperor's Observatory
there's all kinds of interesting stuff
in here including ra7 droids or Death
Star droids these things look like bugs
for some reason they're programmed to
have like really main personalities
they're usually spies actually but like
I said there's a lot of stuff in here
the most fascinating item
far is the one Luke is attracted to Luke
takes his compass and that's the last we
see of it in this game but if you read
all about the behind the scenes of
making Star Wars movies like I do then
this might sound familiar to you we know
that one of the props has been designed
for the upcoming last Jedi movie is a
compass that likely belongs to Luke it
has a blue orb in it now considering
that this mission begins with Luke
saying that something was calling him to
this planet I believe this compass is
attached directly to the force and is
gonna come and play some sort of huge
role for Luke in the last Jedi movie it
also could be related to the map
fragment that lor San Tekka had in the
force awakens that revealed where Luke
went into hiding so if that all ends up
being the case this is a pretty
monumental moment right here in Star
Wars history where Luke first obtains
this compass and as it turns out it
belonged to the Emperor though knowing
him he probably stole it anyway moving
on del then starts to get lost in Luke's
eyes and begins to question everything
he's ever known and Yoda Yoda Yoda you
know the drill and then we get a new
mission for iDEN and company to go back
to her home planet of bardos and get a
hold of Protectorate gleb in the
battlefront book we meet Gleb and learn
that she's basically iDEN and Gideon
asks teacher at the academy and she was
mixed up in their hunt for the dreamers
oh she also held I didn't under house
arrest in the book so they got a pretty
complicated relationship but when I
didn't gets to var DOS we see that the
planet is surrounded by those satellites
that we helped get from the fawned or
shipyards now that info from shattered
Empire is now super relevant because we
know that these things can destroy a
planet and we knew that they were used
on Naboo in the comic but now we're
seeing before that they were rolled out
on idents home planet of our toes
obviously realizing the operations
cinder apparently includes her own home
I didn't is super pissed with her
Admiral daddy
and on the surface of the planet we can
see that bardos is getting geo storm de
hell and really the big new detail here
is the operation cinder seem to be about
squashing potential uprisings and
rebellion but var DOS is a planet whose
loyalty is unquestionable it's an
imperial utopia so this means that the
Dead Emperor wanted to show he was extra
crazy and that everyone should be scared
of the Empire since apparently they'll
wipe out their biggest fans just to
prove a point and then
there's some nice miscible tension that
happens in the ground conversation
between iDEN and hask like this one full
fine Protectorate Gleb in the archive
follow me with I'd ins homeworld clearly
being destroyed you can imagine she's
probably questioning her own loyalty to
the Empire at this moment meanwhile HASC
who has always been gunning for her
position it's implied that he had a
secret conversation with her father the
Admiral and we can only guess it was
about keeping an eye on iDEN and her
potentially waning loyalty so while
Hoffs lying here is on the surface about
her remembering the path to the archive
he's really asking if she's still loyal
oh and I have to point out these really
cool Imperial propaganda posters these
are interesting for reasons both in the
game and out of the game first off
they're obviously heavily inspired by
Nazi propaganda from World War two
and that's one of the most well known
references that the Star Wars franchise
has continued to make each and every
movie especially recently with the
assembly scene in the force awakens and
now these posters keeping that tradition
going however they're also interesting
in the world of the game because these
were designed by Ida and burr CIO's
mother Z hey Z Haber Co was an artist
and she died before the events of the
game but if you read the inferno squad
book you'll come to learn that iDEN was
very concerned about her mother
believing that her daughter was truly
actually a traitor to the Empire and
would die believing that luckily her
mother finds out the truth about item's
mission just before she dies so she can
rest at peace knowing her daughter
stayed loyal to the Empire I'm sure that
I'll never change either
I actually think these posters are
purposely placed here at this stage of
the story because of where we are on Ida
nazar in questioning her own loyalty
these posters are really firmly
reminding her that this place is our
home and her last connection to her
mother also I translated these because
I'm a nerd and while this one says a
monument to security which makes total
sense this other one I want to tell you
it says Stormtrooper Corps and lists
today but it actually says stormtrooper
core enlist today those are two peas
there so you know what maybe I'd ins mom
wasn't the best speller but she's an
artist what do you want from her oh also
if you get close enough to the NPC's in
this stage you might overhear their
frustrations about how they aren't being
allowed to evacuate the planet even
though they are part of the Empire too
I didn't doesn't actually call any of
this out if she overhears it but it
really helps motivate her eventual
change moving forward we get another one
of these subtle sarcastic digs by
Haskett I didn't spoil tea when they
talk about glib and how she the future
Imperial leaders school here crap oil
hold your purse by kindness we also get
a really great look at this statue out
in front of the archive showing just how
big a role her father Admiral versio
played in that same crafting and
brainwashing of the young minds of
future storm Tropper and in this big
climactic scene here I didn't del both
finally realized they can't accept
orders this evil anymore and they really
should be trying to save people right
now so Haase confirms that he is indeed
spying on them for the Admiral and the
only thing I want to point out here is
that these cool trees are very
reminiscent of the weirwood trees of
Game of Thrones and in Westeros those
trees are always witnesses to the great
moments of their history it's
interesting that they're here during
this huge moment in imperial history
where the Inferno squad the most elite
squadron goes rogue all right moving
forward so iDEN and our now on the run
from Imperials and we get to see a few
more new propaganda posters but these
are inspired a bit more by the old
Chinese propaganda posters of Chairman
Mao there's some nice irony here too
because just as this same man depicted
is destroying this very world the Arabic
text translates to versio hero var DOS
the other poster down the way shows some
mixtures of the Nazi look the old
Chinese style and maybe a hint of North
Korean propaganda but note how this
shows that despite what we know about
how the Emperor actually looked at
around this time just all the ugly here
he's still depicted the way he looked
all the way back in the prequels before
he's been disfigured oh and if you're
wondering what all this scrolling text
everywhere is saying it just matches the
announcements we're hearing to watch for
fugitives enemies of the Empire locate
immediately and so on and after we
crossed paths with an adorable mouse
droid ID Hernan del make their way back
to the Corvis to escape and we get a
little pep talk from the Corvis pilot
captain she actually is explored much
more in depth in the novel then we're
off to the outer rim to hideout and you
remember the outer rim where scoundrels
go to hide out and so of course this is
where we'll soon
to lando calrissian real quick i want to
point out that iDEN is worried that if
they hand themselves over to the
rebellion they'll just immediately be
thrown into we're just gonna toss this
in sunspot prison before we can even say
a word that's a fairly new piece of
canon but it gets explored quite a bit
in the recent Star Wars comics sunspot
prison is a pretty cool looking rebel
prison actually floats in space bathed
in the light of a nearby Sun there's a
whole comic run on it you can check out
nonetheless I didn't Adele do turn
themselves over to the rebels and here
we meet shrim who is definitely certain
that these two have to be Imperial spies
and based on not just the history of the
Star Wars universe but also these two
specifically that is a very solid guess
these people do the fake getting caught
thing all the time in fact that's how
this same game started you remember
figured out your watch typical I'm
surprised the rebels didn't just execute
these two as soon as they showed up but
it all makes sense when Lando shows up
and says a reference to the fact that
Lando himself was a bit of a traitor and
then came back and joined the rebellion
and became a general so if anyone gets a
need for second chances it's him then
we're off to Naboo to help defend it
against operation cinder meaning
defended against the satellites from
before and that means we're going to now
live out some of the exact events that
we've seen in the shattered Empire comic
when we get to Naboo we hear that
Princess Leia is among the fighters and
that's interesting because it's a
reminder that we're coming up to just
this really fascinating moment in the
Star Wars lore that I'm gonna get back
to in a second but first off if you're
shocked to see Leia up here in a space
battle that's actually where we see her
in the shattered Empire comic she's in
one of these Naboo and one star fighters
and what's really cool is that that
means here in this moment she's flying
with Shara Bey a badass rebel pilot who
has a little baby boy named Poe Dameron
so yeah up here in this fight alongside
iDEN and del is Princess Leia and Poe
dameron's mom Shara the comic shows us
that Leia and Shara were actually about
to be killed by this Star Destroyer
until apparently Lando and this team
showed up moments later were on the
ground in Naboo fighting as Princess
Leia and I quickly note that this is the
first time we've seen a t-80s on the
boob but the more
thing is that the events depicted here
are actually all leading up to a moment
that is really huge in Star Wars Canon
in shattered Empire as this same battle
is finishing up and Leia welcomes ID
into the rebellion she decides to look
around a little more on Naboo and
suddenly she feels a cold chill and has
a vision of Darth Maul and that is just
awesome honor to hone like on the
surface level but that's also the moment
that confirms that Leia does indeed have
some amount of force sensitivity since
she's experiencing visions and feeling
through Jedi intuition so actually check
it they even match Leah's outfit here to
what she's wearing at this same moment
in the comic except at some point she
swaps the best for a cape because you
know the planet is being geo stormed is
too chilly for a vest also I'm gonna
quickly mention in the multiplayer game
you get to explore the space a bit more
and you see all kinds of Easter eggs in
there too like hey means of a certain
queen of this place who died a long time
ago but moving on after all doubt we
jumped 2 months later and Leia asks I
didn't I need you to find Han sir and
where does she go look taco Danna the
planet we got to know in the force
awakens this is really interesting
because this is all taking place
somewhere around 30 years before the
events of force awakens so seeing young
Han Solo here shows us just how freaking
long him and Maz go back we also learned
that Han is hatching his plan to free
the Wookiees on Kashyyyk that particular
mission is actually a bit of a downer in
the Star Wars lore after the events of
Return of the Jedi Kashyyyk the
homeworld of the Wookiees which had been
under Imperial control for a really long
time at that point it was being ruled by
an imperial ma who pretended that the
emperor was still alive so even after
the original trilogy success and all
that celebration Wookiee still remained
slaves on their own home planet for a
good long while and then we get to
explore the place and just like in force
awakens Mazdas Castle is full of
references most of the little missable
details actually come from overhearing
conversations and right away we hear
about Skye strike Academy which is where
wedge antilles defected from before he
joined the rebellion there's also this
guy who is weirdly obsessed with his
gonk droid
and now this character over here
definitely looks a lot like a younger
version of Prospero mwyn if you watch my
video on Easter eggs in the force
awakens I mentioned that this character
was cut out of the force awakens so you
can still maybe see him floating around
in the background in maz kanata's castle
and in the books about force awakens but
in that period he's a priest who offered
spiritual advice and guidance to the
criminals that were there in the castle
but he himself was a gunrunner before he
was a priest and it's definitely
possible that this is him in his younger
and more criminal days also as email
about some NPCs might mention that they
can't believe Han Solo is there and it's
important to remember yeah he used to be
a criminal just like them but at this
point he's saved the galaxy twice it is
now a general in the rebellion so he's a
nice success story for them someone also
references the Gamecube Akkad being
better than the jorrick cubic odd which
is a reference to Star Wars rebels is a
fittingly Mandalorian game and that it
is played with knives stabbing into a
box it would make sense that there could
be a Mandalorian bounty hunter here
because in the multiplayer outside you
might come across a ship parked that
looks a lot like boba and Jango Fett
slave 1 oh and de jour ik you probably
know it's the game where you should
always let the wookie win elsewhere you
might bump into a patron that says he
wanted to own a bar similar to this
someday and he does kind of look like a
younger version of the bartender from
Maz Eisley cantina so let's go ahead and
count that as a miserable detail and
just in general as you explore the
castle going downstairs into that same
area that was calling to Rey in the
force awakens not only do you see a lot
of chests that are reminiscent of the
one that Ray finds Luke's lightsaber in
30 years later but in the multiplayer
you can actually stand right in front of
the same door that mysteriously opens
for her in the movie and if you listen
closely you'll hear something I have no
idea what it says moving on you can hear
one patron maybe giving himself a pep
talk about a race the race
[Music]
it's pretty clear he's talking about
podracing that's not a stretch when you
remember that the entrance to maz
kanata's castle is adorned by all of
these flags but they're actually
podracer flags the sport may not be very
popular by the time the force awakens
comes around if you remember jakku is
littered with old podracer parts
including ray's cruiser actually but
thirty years earlier that's quite
possible it was still a popular sport
and a quick way to make money another
person makes a quick reference to the
Black Sun still moving cargo for Black
Sun which is an evil crime syndicate
that keeps coming up in various star
wars properties has a now they're tied
up with Darth Maul so katana Sabine Wren
they're just everywhere finally we meet
pal Dora the guy that Han has been
looking for this whole time was gonna
give him some good intel on what he
needs to free the Wookiees and if you
keep him talking which is not too hard
obviously I he'll drop some great in
world trivia and references on first he
mentions his man on the inside is racks
name of racks if you know it you might
be familiar with this character from
chuck wendig's aftermath novel which is
about the events that lead up to the
force awakens' Rex is a pretty
complicated figure he's possibly leaking
Intel here but he's also in charge of
the contingency that's a secret plan the
emperor made in case he died and yes
that sounds a lot like operation cinder
that's because operation cinder is
actually one part of the contingency so
even though cinder is like a big secret
the contingency is an even bigger secret
that's basically about destroying the
entire Empire itself in order to rebuild
it in some better way it's complicated
read aftermath if you keep outdoor
clothes while shooting at stormtroopers
he'll also let you know that
that's a reference to how famously bad
they are at shooting he also lets us
know that pretty quickly the Empire's
onto Han and POW Dora and I love that
Maz won't stop letting Han know how
pissed she is that he brought the Empire
to her castle I think it's fun because
he's gonna do the exact same thing
thirty years later after that bit we
rejoin Ivan who decides she has the head
to best Bindu confront her father the
Admiral as well as her ex subordinate
Gideon Hass honestly this is another one
of those visually amazing parts of this
game so you might remember that best bin
is home to Cloud City but this isn't
Cloud City this is a brand new city here
that shows best thing can actually be a
very scary dark place with what looks
like huge floating monsters in the
clouds these are buildings we've never
officially seen these outside of Star
Wars reference books but they're awesome
actually they can be miles in diameter
and they're kind of like flying
jellyfish they're filled with gas so
they can flow they're not gonna kill you
or anything they're just gonna hunt your
nightmares anyway it's time for Ida and
Dell to pull another classic Star Wars
trope out of the closet just like Han
and Luke and many others they infiltrate
an enemy base by dressing as storm
choppers classic and there's a great
moment around here where I didn't sees a
cloud car and just rags on it look at
that a cloud car I can imagine sitting
in that coffin cloud cars are one of
these dumb vehicles that has a quick
appearance in the original trilogy
specifically they're the car belonging
to the Nerds that give Han Solo guff
when he approaches cloud city
but ever since then they've been seen as
almost a joke of what a lame vehicle can
exist in this galaxy they're kind of
just what your average Cloud City
uber driver might drive like what you
would take your parents for a ride in
when they're visiting from Florida or
floor doing their minivans basically is
what I'm saying
as you progress through the base you can
also overhear stormtrooper mentioning
this is a reference to the iron blockade
that we learn about in the aftermath
novel basically it is a physical
blockade led by governor ADA hard but
it's really about blocking information
the purpose of it was to try to totally
block the news at the emperor had died
and that the empire was mostly defeated
and keep it just totally out of the
Anoat sector that's where best been in
Hawthorne interestingly this blockade
story was gonna be explored in some
other properties but some of them were
actually canceled so this line is just
one little bit of closure that we get on
that story that indeed yeah this
blockade started to fall apart
also executing another Star Wars trope
just like how Vader lets rebels land on
Endor on purpose it's an older code sir
but it checks out leave them to me
it turns out here that della niden were
allowed to infiltrate and of course it's
a trap and hassed escapes then we get
one of my favorite references in the
game this epic moment standoff right
here is a huge reference to rogue one a
lot of people were frustrated when the
trailers for rogue one showed us this
awesome moment at the top of a platform
where jyn erso is facing down a TIE
fighter on her own but then that moment
ended up not being in the movie well
that's exactly what we have here now we
get to play it with it we're at the top
of a tall platform in Titan versio is
staring down a big old TIE fighter and
it's honestly it's just awesome and then
to get away from here after all that
smack that I didn't talked about the
cloud car not only does it provide great
cover during a firefight she also has to
use it to get out of there and I just
love that because if you catch it fast
enough the new mission objective becomes
settle for the cloud car and of course
the cloud car saves the day and then
we're off to solace you might remember
it as where the rebels were regrouping
the fleet before the Battle of Endor or
the home planet of those guys you think
all look alike the designs for solace
were created for battlefront and they're
actually based on the lava flows of
Iceland and you can see photographers
sampled that look with little mini
stormtroopers I love that and then on
the surface of Solace we actually play
as Lando alongside our new homeboy
Shrieve investigating what's supposed to
be an abandoned Imperial Factory and we
get another obligatory Star Wars
reference right here you have a bad
feeling about this and if you get shrimp
talking which is not hard he mentions
helping liberate this planet give you
I know my way around solace after all
place he's actually referring to the
same plan I mentioned at the beginning
of this video where the rebels were
trying to get the Empire to bring its
forces over to Sullust and abandon Endor
liberating Sullust was supposed to be
the cover mission for that plan but
again the old man knew all about it so
he said he's a move ensued and so the
plan didn't work and that of course led
to the other old fish man saying it's a
trap and all that stuff went down but
Haylie solace was liberated shrim also
reveals that he was a part of helping
free Han Solo from Jabba spalatin you
know I remember Lando being there he was
in disguise oh maybe Shrieve was there
but he was also in disguise maybe he's
this guy but I mean wow I guess a little
did we know SHhhh rivers some major hero
it has just been like forgotten by
history poor guy
oh and we also get one of the most
obscure references I found in a moment
where shrimp finds them a way to escape
and Lando says I could get sued those
happen to be the exact words said to
Lando in the Star Wars legends book
crucible there's a very attractive kind
of flirty Jedi woman in that book named
it to hurry and she says that to Lando
and he kind of like blushes and is
flattered that book actually was the
final book written before Disney came in
and was like none of that counts it's
all in on Canon now is legend so his
exchange with the hot Jedi lady has now
been erased and he gets to have it with
trips
sorry Lando now after this mission you
have to realize this actually ends up
being another really big impact to the
overall Star Wars story the factory that
wasn't abandoned and was secretly fully
operational on solist
it had been supplying the Empire still
but since it was destroyed in the
previous mission that gives Admiral
Ackbar the entire idea to send the
entirety of the rebel fleet to jakku the
planet we meet in the force awakens and
whose deserts are littered with the
remains of that battle that's because
that's where what's left of the Imperial
fleet is currently hiding out and now
that they don't have any of the
reinforcements equipment they were
hoping for from SOLAS like 80s teas and
whatnot they're now vulnerable so
Akbar's planned for the huge final
battle of the Galactic Civil War to
completely wipe out the Empire this
whole thing was actually caused by the
actions
of lando calrissian and damn it can you
believe it shrimp so then we get to
witness this battle firsthand and we did
get a glimpse at it before in the first
battlefront DLC but this is still a huge
deal we're at the final battle between
the Empire and the rebels the battle of
jakku and I'll point out even though
we've already heard it a bunch of times
before this siren here this is the
loudest and clear as we hear it it's the
same Imperial arm that's been around
since the original trilogy and it shows
up all the way through recent movies in
some ways it's become a bit of its own
musical score adding some serious
tension in the most climactic scenes of
movies and games Nanda's item provides
support to the rebels we hear the
Starhawk unity is looking for help in
penetrating the Empire's formation this
is unity we can't find a cap in the
empire formation so just know that
iDEN is now playing a role in the events
of the third Star Wars aftermath novel
empires end a cool detail about the
unity is that it's built in the Nadira
dockyards which is interesting because
that's not a fancy shipbuilding place
like the fondler shipyards that the
empire uses it's more like a recycling
yard where the rebels take the Empire's
captured ships or ship remnants and they
use all that fancy tech and they make
their own half-decent ships out of it I
just have always loved how scrappy the
rebels are oh and when I said I didn't
is playing a role in that story it's not
exactly a helpful one they're asking bro
but items more like nah we're good I
like this size it's everyone for
themselves best thing we could do is
focus on what's down here speaking of
what's down here you'll notice that all
these air fights are causing the ground
to be littered with ships from both
sides and while it's really hard to
identify which one is which we still
know one of them for sure as I pointed
out in my analysis of the force awakens
we know one of these ships is the
inflictor rey actually rides right past
it in that movie but the story of that
ship coming to its end here on jakku
it's actually the plot of the Star Wars
novel lost stars and it's actually a
really entertaining read it's very
similar to the story that's taking place
here in battlefront 2 but imagine if
instead of these two very close heroes
and item versio and del miko both
leaving the empire and joining the
rebels what if one of them did not flip
to the other side and instead was put in
charge of a Star Destroyer but the two
still remain in love with each other and
this battle here on jakku it's the other
ones mission to take down that Star
Destroyer commanded by the person they
love is drama go read it okay now next
up we have one of my favorite references
because it's a two for one at one point
you have to give some help to a rebel
pilot referred to as captain Lindsay now
that's not a well-known character by any
means the only thing we've ever heard
about captain Lindsay is somewhere in
Star Wars lore he owns a ship and pilots
it and it's currently stashed at Maz
Eisley cantina so that's a pretty
obscure reference sure but Jacques
Lindsey is actually a reference to
another jock Lindsey from a George Lucas
movie he's the pilot in Raiders of the
Lost Ark you can also have a drink at
his hangar bar in Disney World and now
that we're nearing the end of the story
after iDEN has shot down her game long
foe of hask and his TIE fighter we come
to a full circle promise with iDEN
saying that
the Empire died this is a great parallel
to the beginning of the story today the
rebellion dies except this time she also
happens to be mostly right since this
really is the Empire's last big stand
and then in the final moments of the
battle of jakku we get another Star Wars
trope fulfillments specifically
regarding trying to mend some daddy
issues so just like Luke at the end of
Return of the Jedi
hyden infiltrates an imperial ship to
try and get her pretty evil father to
safety before the ship or a Death Star
in Luke's case is destroyed now the game
seems to end when iDEN gets off the
Eviscerator and the rebels have won and
the battle of jakku is over but then it
does the coolest thing it jumps forward
approximately thirty years and we go
back to pilio that's a planet where del
met Luke and Luke got that compass and
we see a very familiar first order
shuttle cuz it belongs to kylo Ren and
it lands next to the ship that we've
come to know and love throughout this
game the Corvis except remember this is
thirty years later and just before we
reveal kylo Ren we get a POV shot that's
a reference to the opening stormtrooper
saw at the beginning of the force
awakens and really this whole section is
now a direct lead-in to the events of
the force awakens and they're also
exactly in line with the events of the
poe dameron comic in all of these kylos
on that same hunt that we found him on
throughout the movie starting there with
hunting down lor san tekka but here -
he's just desperate for that map that's
gonna lead to Luke Skywalker and then an
even more powerful version of the mind
interrogation that we saw in force
awakens get out of my head we see that
kylo can actually explore and walk
through the memories of a person he's
interrogating which also sets up one of
the most fun sequences of the game where
you play as kylo Ren fighting against
Del's of mind blocks and then comes
another one of my favorite references
it's not pointed out directly at all but
if you remember delle rose through the
ranks in his career and one of his early
missions when he was with the Empire was
actually at the Battle of scurry from
rogue one and this memory that we're
living through is the exact same
location as the really intense Beach
sequence where cheered in ways walk in
and Bay's mal misses shooting in that
movie and turns out del was right there
with them the whole time just on the
other side and we have another big
adjustment to the Star Wars historical
Canon when I believe but I can't tell
for sure kylo Ren wipes out all of the
mind block soldiers del is using in this
grief section he suddenly now knows part
of the map secret that was a question a
lot of people had about the force
awakens how did kylo Ren know that lor
san tekka had the Skywalker map and it
seems like this could be the moment he
found out by torturing del Miko and then
as Kyle keeps exploring Dale's memories
we hear a lot about item but then he
specifically drops this quick line
this being 30 years later it's really
likely that there is a current young
woman in the Star Wars universe who is
yet to be revealed as the daughter of
del miko and i denver CO here's hoping
we actually meet her in another property
and then when del finally cracks in
tells kylo Ren that lor san tekka took
the map to bey aura that's actually not
a place that i've ever heard of and it's
not where kylo eventually finds lor san
tekka later he took it to Bey or so my
guess is that could be where a dlc or
another story could maybe still fill in
some gaps at some point and then as we
head toward our fairly sad ending here
somehow despite thinking he was dead
gideon hask shows up so that means a
hask not only survived the moments at
the end of the battle of jakku by the
looks of the uniform it also appears
he's joined the first order and this is
really interesting because the new movie
trilogy has definitely shown us a good
amount of rebels from the original
trilogy that are still fighting the good
fight 30 years later cloody Nina but
this is one of our only examples of a
bad guy making it from the days of the
original trilogy over to the new trilogy
and then we get one of the biggest
bombshells were left with del begs hask
not to go after item which means item
versio hero battlefront two badass older
she's still out there in the current
timeline of Star Wars and the new
trilogy 30 years older were probably
still kicking ass which is amazing like
I think she's alive during the last Jedi
unfortunately ha skills del but that
also means iDEN is probably gonna be
pretty pissed I'm looking for some
vengeance moments later Protectorate
Gleb shows up and she drops the name of
Project resurrection and basically the
game ends there so that definitely
leaves us with a big mystery that is
currently taking place during the
current Star Wars movies what is project
resurrection our characters being
resurrected like has we thought he was
dead so maybe maybe we'll find out more
in the upcoming DLC all right you guys
I've been feeling Melina I am spent this
felt like doing a breakdown I'm an
entire trilogy but oh my god this game
is so good like I don't even touch on
the multiplayer but that was amazing too
especially the awesome heroes vs.
villains mode also let me know if you're
interested in more gaming related
content from us and also let me know
what you think project resurrection is
all about if you have any questions
about the campaign story you can tweet
at me at fimo and as always make sure to
also follow add new
sors because that's where we post what
videos are in the pipeline all right
let's get me into that back to tank see
you next time bye